I did for cation this is session fifteen with faith bender
and Karen Craig recorded in Sydney on Wednesday the first of October one thousand nine hundred ninety seven
and tape starts in a few seconds.
I thought I should record a few of the things I want to remember one was the day that I had the radio on to set a time
when I listened to Parliament every day it was broadcast mainly because it was worth listening to.
And I couldn't believe what I was hearing. I just couldn't and the government was being sect and I sat through.
In the middle of November the beginning of. Nine hundred seventy five. So I want to remember to write about that.
And the effect that.
Not on me personally it had an effect on make me of course because I thought of democracy is all about in this country.
You know I've got a very suspicious man when it comes to politics and I felt that the CIA were in for that very minute.
Because we had pool. Had pulled the troops out of. The prison doors were open on the conscripts came out.
If I could just go back to the night with them was elected and we had a whole crowd of people here.
They were a freeway they were down the back Malone they were in the picture room and we had extra television sets
and masses of grog because we were so sure that would lead and.
The people just went ahead and I recall a friend of mine. Who was here that night and Paula had to say University.
One could have been called. And the tears came to her and she said Michael.
You know it was just quite amazing the tremendous impact it had on a house because we've gone.
We were sick and fed up to the teeth of demonstrating against the involvement we had in war and now we come to power.
And it was all over him. It was hard to believe. It.
Well I want to remember that and then I also remember another incident. We packed up. And went to London. And.
Because he had to go to Tokyo. So he went to Turkey. And the lawn and I travelled later in joined him in London.
And we had Christmas dinner with the other panelists in London. I wasn't awfully happy about that because we.
To celebrate Christmas we didn't celebrated we didn't believe in giving presents
and all that because we didn't know what it was all about
and he were tied up with relations who placed tremendous effort. Making sure everyone had a president and all that.
Even to this day I find it grinding. Because it's so meaningless. Why does it all of it.
And that's how I've always felt any. We went over to London. And I think. Oh that's right.
We stayed in Bloomsbury hotel.
And it was a very hotel that I had stayed in and not in fifty one and the beginning that nine hundred fifty two.
Was nice. Anyhow. Then we decided to go over to Vienna. And we went and spent some time. First in Amsterdam and Paris.
Oh that was a wonderful holiday in Paris absolutely marvelous. You know it's a mass romantic city in the world.
I'm sure even in the bitter cold and the sleet and drink coffee but we had great big coats big full coats and gloves
and they were going to be here now where it was three degrees.
And we stayed in a pinch you know in there
and we had a good friendship with those people each time I went back to the and I After that we stayed in the same.
Place but. Had relations. Who were bloody good Nazis. When he was taken off to.
In nineteen thirty nine when the Germans in Austria.
Because the Austrians turned out to be better Nazi Germany Germans did
and they couldn't persecute the Jews quickly enough. Once the Germans moved in.
You could have it used to get down in the streets
and scrub the streets the Austrians went into the universities to pick that used up and threw them out of the wind
and hunt was arrested and taken to a concentration camp he had relations. Brianna. Who said that they wanted to use.
While a father was at them our house or being vice versa. I'm quite sure.
And they certainly kept their distance from hundreds. And I think one of us actually in the German army.
After all those years. We had they were full of guilt. They did nothing about it.
He was into concentration camp they did nothing to get him out. So if you fall again over backwards to.
And to Tallahassee and. So we've had Christmas in London. And we spent New Year's Eve in Paris.
And I really must tell you the bit.
We arrived in the afternoon we had a rest and they said We decided we'd go out to dinner.
So we went out to someone in London told us that office at the pub we were staying in. Was a very little restaurant.
So we walked a few blocks and family way came back and we said I think.
We have to look at the bad they would had some grog. And there was a black voter with the main your pets.
And the price. So I look at the menu. I say it's it would only be something like ten dollars each for a forgotten.
It's just I've just forgotten but anyhow or so we thought about his and food in Paris.
So we go back and we freshen up a basin where welcomed at the door and. Lovely table such to me I have never in.
Perfection. Right. And what's a very special quite a big face and the face and head feel in our face.
And then came the cheese a huge platter of. Whole cheeses and the wine flat we were getting pretty early and.
Now I was thinking if it wasn't so cheap pop one of those cheeses in my handbag photo morrow.
And just picked the bread up in the market. You know that not worth that cheap. And I did.
Pay this you know covered in chocolate covered with cream and all that and coffee with brandy to follow.
Well no they didn't we were pretty early. So around about midnight we asked for the bill.
I put the comma in the wrong place. I looked at the black book and it was one hundred thirty dollars. Each for forty.
Here. So I thought of what am I going to do. And how.
This is how he's got no Martin or bad money he says don't worry I've got to travel. I'm an American travelers.
And our super who will cross the Red Cross Street and get it so I sit here in Gaza.
You know what I had to look you know and he came back and I said What's it with Holmes.
He says with fifteen dollars and I said and I saw both of us more show you up for the rest of the night. Well.
I was traveling with Swiss francs traveler's checks. So when the way to our SIT look. Will you take Swiss francs.
He could not speak English. And we battled through with. His English came go to.
So you met him that is no trouble at all. Would you like to come into the office and. If. We had a really crazy.
They knew you went over to Vietnam and I do want to record this because. I just come back to this. And hear the.
Two questions. And they've grown up children in their thirty's and children. And then another.
Distant or another cousin or. And they were all full of excuses you know. Or of course you know.
We had to respect the two women. And I felt very uncomfortable when they these people.
And lean on my secret after distaste.
But they you know cut off from the rest of the world theory you knew were very limited. They're not great travel.
They may be now a bit but not awfully plain.
And there was no other city in the world as far as they were concerned and. So you know we said to each other look.
Here's something which we did twice.
And so forth but they kept insisting on reading up and then we have cousins who were right. Well you know.
Full of guilt. Running up and said You must come. We want to have a be identified. To welcome you. Wow. Thanks.
Sandy power. And when I say to lean on them. You've got a long trace put it down. Oh I'm not coming. Where I went.
Those days in the seventy's were wearing those wonderful long and I had a great long skirt and a red jacket
and hence had a blue suit. We did. Well you're wrong. I think. They were coming in. Women. With long black. Long white.
Yes and. In a private. This is a strange.
So music is playing the Blue Danube but if they played it once I played it a thousand times.
And there's there was a ballroom downstairs. So good and well all day.
There was something extremely unpleasant about it. It's hard for me to tell you that. It left a bad taste in my mouth.
And I was falling over backwards to do things for Homs. And Iran and so I think with that happened.
We couldn't we were snowed in. So we had to stay till seven o'clock in the morning.
The people that I'm still not through yet. Oh yes. Like to throw that another year. Absolutely absolutely.
So the next festival was about to start about a week after that insult.
And you know when you think of that poor man die. And.
There is the tray at the mouth of the Mozart express every for the Thomas full of Mozart chocolates.
Mozart on the legs so much they live so long I wanted to go over and hear a concert
and Ham said to one have his relations.
So the next thing we have a telephone call from Salzburg from the upper stinkingly rich horrible Nazi.
Well she will stay with us. She says Oh I poked into these hostel. So. They didn't trouble us after that.
But it was a very interesting visit to that point.
It was the only time I'd ever had any contact with hamsters for elections and it was.
Good to stand back and watch their very peculiar behavior. They'd lined up beautifully with the Nazis. Yes.
Anyhow I want to just move on a little if I might and say that. On one occasion.
And this is I have to lean on and Stephen Moore marry him.
To England and we think about staying for a while and usually. So we're coming. And. Let's get a cottage.
So she organized. We stayed at a little village. We went from London to Vienna where we picked up a couple.
And went from they had her over to Florence and this was about.
Forty miles out from Florence Baca I just forgotten the title of the. Really. Doesn't matter but it was.
And we had one poor. The servants' quarters to the castle. Which was opposite. There was a rough road.
And they have your original Castle which was built in the fourteenth century
and the Count who had practically the whole of the mountain.
And opposite where the servants' quarters which he was slated for. What we post what we rented it was magnificent.
To abstain bedrooms but the plainest of Tuscany. And still only original kitchen you know here and.
When we arrived during the face of the Phoenix. And the figs were only a small orange and green. And I was looking.
In the atlas to try and find the place fig leaf. It's called That was the village but no we were up on the top.
But the neighbors came including the count and say.
Well the we'll have a festival and some food and dancing in lineage. It's very welcome. I make the local people so.
It was just so lovely. So we said yes we'd go down but it so happened. That.
I mean the mayor of Florence who was out as a guest and it was a communist Council. And I brought to this town.
Usually you know. And they turned it on and. Cheek wonderful pestis.
And a band and we still have danced out in the square here. So then no one was much.
But we didn't and we picked up a couple of bottles and took them out. So the next afternoon.
We were sitting outside in the courtyard. Drinking the wine and the Count came over to ask us if we'd like to go.
To have a drink with him and we said oh no you must you know it's we.
We pick someone up down at the very moment when you have a glass
and he looked at the bottle he said I don't usually have one quite so true for you Do you want to go.
And he happened to be. He happened to be an exporter of why.
He had a right sellers and huge invasion yards and he exported into a place that it was again so we sat there
and he looked at the label and he said Oh it's a little early for me I think so.
That was one of the missed enjoyable experience is staying up there in the. In Tuscany.
I wanted to put that on because. I should never forget the fun we had on the film. And the hospitality. Well.
If all you've often spoken about in the course of these recordings your love of Italy.
And we went down to we left a little arm and Stephen there. And then I got a train to Rome for her. We could.
And he could never get me away from her. After that but it's strange to us you know and I have met.
It's like I could see it coming and. I thought about it and I thought well. It's not quite what I want to do.
When I travel the world so many tourists but now.
You go to the airport and it's almost impossible it's horrible horrible. So pleased that I did it before it became or.
Now I just want to say I want to remember that for the eighty in particular.
And I also want to deal in great detail when I'm actually getting the book together of my experiences with.
The Housing Commission in greater detail. And the foundation.
And I have that's all very well documented so that when people problem.
And if we just go into the ninety's you know why the ninety's have been very peaceful.
It's been now it's just being at home and. I'm tormented quite by television channels which are right. Right.
Yeah I don't like that.
I kind of feel I've had my front and these days I just want to I want to because I enjoy it but sliced.
Just like to say something about how you're feeling about after the big reconciliation Convention
and all those demands on your time and you know the celebration of the one nine hundred sixty seven referendum
but how you're feeling now about the future here Indigenous people are I'm very hopeful. That.
As far as the Aboriginal people are concerned. Been rough but they will get there. And there is one thing I know.
That they will never give up their fight for their right to the land.
Now they're going to know about the reconciliation contention. Was one of the great experiences. It was a time to.
And it was a time to make a man. There was a lot of warmth in that place. I'm sure that everyone who when they felt.
That there was a renewing of the Spirit as it were. I didn't want to come back and be active.
For me it was like closing a chapter. And somehow I felt I could close the chapter and say.
All right now as far as I'm concerned. I know that the battle the work battle the battle for the week.
Is going to be difficult. But I know. That there are a foul out there. Hundreds of us.
Who see the injustice of the ten point plan of how. And I truly believe that the embers. Have far more on this.
And I fully realize.
The convention was like the chapter in my life as it were happening and I had seen the anger in the deuce trace
and the disappointment. But then that coming together. Was very positive and there's a groundswell today.
And I think we'll leave it.